première réponse beverly hills
telle est la première série dans
laquelle eva longoria à tanger a
exactement quel sirat ont pu voir pour
la première fois et horgen zh en 2000
eva longoria obtient son premier rôle à
la télévision dans beverly hills on
rappelle
mme mba
oui je m'en rappelle très bien c'est
grâce à cette apparition qu'à se faire
opérer pour jouer après dans les feux de
l'amour ah c'est un bon souvenir c'est
un bon souvenir ça les feux de l'amour
oui tout à fait c'est un bon souvenir ça
ou pas et
donc je vais pas là je mets pas là je
mets pas d'image alors est d'accord non
mais franchement non mais c'est vrai
donc je n'ai pas dit m je la mets pas
elle était hôtesse de l'air il semble
très méchant avec moi ah oui c'est vrai
je vais retrouver chez les escarpins
je te le dis je te dis je vais d'escorté
je lis je vais des scripts et j'aime pas
être tout l'été les champs avec toi qui
dans les feux de l'amour des chouettes
copains loisirs en fait c'est vraiment
la même charte et les jeunes que la
première fois là c'était pas très sympa
avec moi je n'ai pas pire souvenir de
mes des feux de l'amour accor est celle
arrêtée je vais l'art et l'art et
tu vas apprendre à me connaître
ça rigole pas ça rigole pas si vous avez
des questions posées les bases n'hésitez
pas à grossir si je parlais bien entendu
alors 40,8 millions qu'elle est question
oui quel est le revenu annuel de cyril
hanouna
non sans tirer s'annoncer plus
vous faites passer le vent un moins que
rien
[Rires]
le nombre de lettres de jeunes femmes
qui ont appris que vous étiez
célibataire et qui souhaite vous
convoitez ouais ben laden est sorti
[Applaudissements]
non sérieux
par combien de téléspectateurs et avait
vu dans le monde desperate housewives sa
classe ce 40,8 mina bon début
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais vous dire je regarde je
regarde pas ce que je regarde grave
parce que sa soeur d'aironi français à
0,9 sur toutes les chaînes de desperate
house aurait versé sur téva au sultan
donc comme moi je travaille pas beaucoup
un jour gagnent énormément les rues et
je trouve franchement et c'est vrai que
c'est pas de la flagornerie eva est une
actrice incroyable qu'elle a vraiment
une un sens comique non mais vraiment
mais dans un sens économique un sens du
rythme incroyable vraiment joli les vans
c'est un fou parce que vendre des vannes
c'est très dur et vous seriez bam bam
bam c'est vous le savez c'est toujours
vous êtes drôles comme ça dans la vie
aussi meas et non en commun
hodgson a grandi nous étions quatre
filles dans la famille et moi je suis là
et tout mais elles sont un monde aux
yeux et donc je suis prête à fait on
après il avait fait à ses yeux c'est à
dire l'athlète le vilain petit canard
[Rires]
du canard donc est-ce qu'on est non
j'aurais aimé mais attendez si vous vous
êtes le vilain petit canard
un homme vous êtes et toutes vos soeurs
sont très bonnes ben yahia d'abeilles
oui
mais
l'om a peur et donc en gens aller voir
mes filles et 10ème et bosselée elles
sont magnifiques et celle là c'est
qu'ils
étaient éligibles à être drôle y en a
presque quand j'étais petit je n'étais
pas à bell et oui ensuite j'ai cru
devenir vraiment comme une fois la
vérité je serais extrêmement nerveux
bravo cerveau c'est un peu comme vous un
tiens vaut aussi mais n'était pas le but
et un petit canal à une âpre lutte est
pas moche alors juste toujours été vous
concernant il avait reconnu c'est le
joker
[Rires]
c'est la vie c'est ma mère dans ce match
à temps mais aujourd'hui où il ya dix
ans mais ce rappel se
laissera pas faire on a vu la photo nous
tu te dois bien ça y est
maintenant c'est bien
fait non mais elle est correct c'est
tout simplement parce que c'est une
évidence
oui c'est vrai
je n'en peux plus je n'en peux plus
depuis week et 6 passes je peux poser
une question à eva sur cette série
desperate housewives alors déjà
prononcés bien parce que cette série
elle a révolutionné le monde de la
télévision quand on vous a proposé le
rôle de gabrielle solis vous avez tout
de suite senti que c'était le rôle de
votre vie qui allez vous faire connaître
au monde entier
non
c'était l' effort une série
et moi je pensais que j'allais se
seraient déroulés en fait on a fait un
épisode pilote
l'épisode pilote a été gouverné il a
décidé de continuer et chaque chaîne a
décidé de ne pas la prendre a refusé de
diffuser en dix ans le scénario est
mauvais
ici c'était vraiment la chaîne la mois à
ses sièges dont personne ne regardait
d'ici à noël cette chaîne nbc et
donc ils ont décidé de me diffuser ça a
été un phénomène mondial je me rappelle
que je me suis même en vue en chine les
gens me disaient de gaby oh gaby partout
aussi bien c est une star mondiale c'est
ça ça fait quoi d'être une star mondiale
c'est à dire que c'est parce que moi je
suis une star dans mon quartier
dès que je sors un petit peu de douala
dans mon quartier de bois de mon pâté de
maison je ne reconnais plus vous serrez
que tous les pays vous êtes une star
mondiale c'est difficile à vivre c'est
un énorme kif
je me rappelle d'une peau où je suis
allé en est jamais oublier la clé
vraiment très engageant bruxelles et
puis les posters de glander qui
couvraient tout le mur extérieur ligue
at-elle
parce que j'avais pas ma clé
dans ce que vous pouvez entendre ici et
là laissez moi
non non non non vous n'avez pas la
classe et à montrer donc parfois on peut
être mais la célébrité ça vous sert à
rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]